immer wieder gibt es sehr kritische
kommentare unter unseren videos die rede
ist vom wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern oder von astronauten
astronauten oder von forschenden oder
auch von expertinnen von einer
geschlechtergerechten sprache also und
die kritiker ich nehme mal an dass es
war ein männer waren haben ja quasi mit
ihrem getrennte darum gebettelt eine
studie dazu zu bekommen hier ist sie und
die ergebnisse sind echt ziemlich
beeindruckend dass es so krass ist hätte
ich nicht gedacht kriegs und science
fiction estate die spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's willkommen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
moment ich mach's noch härter liebe
zuschauer innen bei google wird das
übrigens inzwischen schon in der
autokorrektur angeboten auch wenn diese
anrede einigen nicht gefallen wird das
lassen jedenfalls eure kommentare
vermuten das zeigen auch befragungen zum
beispiel die repräsentative umfrage des
vereins der deutschen sprache aus dem
vergangenen jahr 2019
demnach ist die mehrheit der deutschen
gegen eine gander neutrale sprache
sie wird als überflüssig und lästig
empfunden neun von zehn der befragten
nutzen demnach auch privat keine
geschlechtergerechte sprache das ist
aber ein riesiges problem mit fatalen
konsequenzen und da ist sich die
wissenschaft einig und wir sind ja ein
wissenschafts kanal
denn die sprache hilft enorm dabei
frauen sichtbar zu machen obwohl wir das
jahr 2020 haben fragt man bei
nebenwirkungen noch immer nur den zitat
arzt oder apotheker gibt es neue
erkenntnisse aus der wissenschaft waren
halt wissenschaftler und forscher
beteiligt und das witzige ist selbst
wenn die teams nur aus frauen bestehen
die frauen also ärztinnen und
apothekerinnen sowie die
wissenschaftlerinnen und forscherin
seien ja mit gemeint doch studien
demonstrieren die macht der sprache
und wenn jemand von einem arzt spricht
denken wir tatsächlich auch eher an
einen mann die frau aber die diesen
medizinischen beruf ausübt gibt dabei
hinten über in einer studie die bereits
vor knapp zehn jahren stattfand wurde
nach berühmten persönlichkeiten gefragt
lautete die aufgabe nennen sie drei
politiker nannten die befragten
tatsächlich deutlich mehr männer als bei
der aufgabenstellung die explizit nach
politikern und politikerinnen fragte
auch bei anderen fragestellungen
hatten die testpersonen deutlich mehr
frauen wenn die formulierung länder
gerecht war
die linguistin karin wemhoff sagt dass
geschlechtergerechte sprache einen
großen einfluss hat und eine andere
sicht auf die welt schafft gedankliche
einbezug bewirkt wahrnehmen von chancen
macht träume aufzeigt beteiligung von
frauen an kulturellen leistungen und
historischen ereignissen auf weitere
studien zeigen auch ganz deutlich dass
kindergerechte sprache dabei helfen kann
die gleichstellung von frau und mann
nach vorne zu bringen in einer
untersuchung aus dem jahr 2015 hatten
expertinnen kindern im vorschulalter job
bezeichnung vorgelesen einmal nur und
das ist jetzt wirklich krass in der
männlichen form also beispielsweise
ingenieure und geschäftsführer zum
anderen aber auch in einer
kindergerechten sprache also in unserem
beispiel ingenieure und ingenieurinnen
und geschäftsführer und
geschäftsführerin bei letzterem schätzen
die mädchen diese berufe als
erreichbarer für sie ein und trauten
sich demnach auch eher zu diesem job für
sich selbst auszuwählen spricht schon im
kindesalter werden mit der männlichen
form gedanken und vorstellungen geformt
die später das leben konkret
beeinflussen hammer ein klarer beleg
dafür dass sprache ein wichtiges mittel
im kampf gegen diskriminierung ist woran
also liegt es dass ländern so unbeliebt
ist ein argument was oft genannt wird
ist die ästhetik lesbarkeit und
verständlichkeit von texten
doch auch das hat die wissenschaft
bereits entkräftet ein experiment aus
dem vergangenen jahr 2009 10 konnte
zeigen dass es bezüglich der
verständlichkeit keine signifikanten
unterschiede zwischen der sogenannten
maskulinen form und der plattform gibt
das wurde an unterschiedlich
formulierten stromverträgen getestet in
denen einmal nur die zitat kontoinhaber
angesprochen wurden und zum anderen in
der plattform nämlich die zitat
kontoinhaber oder kontoinhaberin die
befragten hielten die zweite version
allerdings für weniger ästhetisch doch
sprach forschende lassen dieses argument
nicht zu dazu die expertin claudia
posche sprache ist nicht dazu da schön
oder hässlich zu sein auch die bedenken
dass durch eine geschlechtergerechte
sprache der lesefluss gestört wird lässt
die wissenschaft nicht zu denn um worte
zu lesen und es zu erfassen sind nur
wenige anhaltspunkte möglich und
experimente zeigen dass lesen und
verstehen auch gut funktioniert wenn die
buchstaben komplett durcheinander sind
das wort wenn man ein wort nimmt wo ende
und anfang gleich sind und dazwischen
die buchstaben einfach durcheinander
mixed werden die trotzdem ganz leicht
gewesen
das größere problem beim kindern sind
offensichtlich die gefühle die bei
vielen uns dadurch ausgelöst werden denn
damit wird etwas in frage gestellt was
wir seit vielen jahren anders kennt
möglicherweise fühlt man sich dadurch
auch bedroht und bekehrt also persönlich
angegriffen
manche männer empfinden das thema sogar
als gefährlich dazu an alice kaiser
professorin für gender studies in
freiburg vielen männern macht das sogar
angst sie fürchten dass ihnen mit der
zusätzlichen betonung anlage schächter
im übertragenen sinne selbst weniger
raum gegeben wird dass man ihnen
vielleicht auch auf anderer ebene etwas
wegnimmt doch an dieser stelle ist es
höchste zeit unsere routinen zu
überdenken und aus unserer eigenen
komfortzone heraus zu kommen denn klar
ist geschlechtergerechte sprache ist
arbeit und dafür braucht es motivation
dabei ist uns bei klicks und klar dass
es schon helfen würde wenn einige von
uns geschlechtergerechte sprache selbst
bewusst und zielgerichtet in unseren
alltag integrieren würden und das machen
wir bei pixum und darauf sind wir auch
stolz denn wir sind von diesem
standpunkt absolut überzeugt und wie es
die wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse
ja bestätigt haben die stützen uns und
teilweise schon seit dreißig jahren
natürlich haben wir nicht das recht
unsere sprache anderen aufzuzwingen also
ihr könnt formulieren und kommentieren
wie ihr wollt aber wir können als
vorbild vorangehen und jede und jeder
bekommt zeit und raum sich seine eigenen
gedanken dazu machen also in diesem
sinne freue ich mich auf eine angeregte
sachliche diskussion in diesem video as
kommentare oder jede form der
unsachlichkeit werde ich entsprechend
behandelt und in diesem video geht es
noch um mehr was ist mit den anderen
geschlechtern also denen außer weiblich
und männlich aufruf gegen kindergerechte
sprache also anklicken anschauen aber
auf jeden fall klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran